Caption: [Applause]
Caption: I want you to use your imagination for a
Caption: few months I want you to imagine that as
Caption: you're sitting there talk listening to
Caption: me today that the person sitting next to
Caption: you takes a phone call while you're
Caption: trying to listen now I want you to
Caption: imagine that a couple of the people
Caption: sitting behind you start a conversation
Caption: maybe they're talking about a TV show
Caption: you like to watch or maybe they're
Caption: talking about a problem that they don't
Caption: know how to solve but you do imagine
Caption: that's happening while the person
Caption: sitting next to you on the phone while
Caption: you're sitting there trying to listen to
Caption: the talk now imagine that on the other
Caption: side of the room from where you're
Caption: sitting somebody starts playing music
Caption: and they having a good time laughing and
Caption: cheering and carrying on imagine that's
Caption: going on well the people behind you
Caption: having a conversation well the person
Caption: sitting next you is still on the phone
Caption: and while you're trying to listen to me
Caption: - now imagine that we're not all sitting
Caption: down but there's actually people walking
Caption: around they're walking between you and I
Caption: they're walking down the corridors and
Caption: some of them are trying to catch your
Caption: attention and engage you in a
Caption: conversation imagine that's happening
Caption: while the people on the other side of
Caption: the room is still having a good time
Caption: there's people behind you having a good
Caption: time someone's going to find next to you
Caption: and all you want to do is sit there and
Caption: listen to me talk how effective do you
Caption: think you can focus on what I'm saying
Caption: with all that going on so modern
Caption: workplaces have trended towards these
Caption: open-plan working environments and the
Caption: people who plan these workspaces do it
Caption: for a number of reasons but mainly they
Caption: think that people collaborate more
Caption: efficiently in this sort of environment
Caption: and they also do it because they don't
Caption: have to put up internal walls or
Caption: partitions and move them around as the
Caption: structure of their organization changes
Caption: to workplace planners open-plan working
Caption: is a win-win situation there are no
Caption: downsides but what they fail to
Caption: recognize is that only about half the
Caption: human population work positively under
Caption: these conditions in the 1920s a
Caption: psychologist called car young
Caption: popularized a theory it was a theory of
Caption: the personality trait continuum
Caption: it was the theory that people's people's
Caption: personalities can be categorized between
Caption: two extremes between introversion and
Caption: extraversion you know the theory is
Caption: actually quite detailed and that's too
Caption: complicated to be absorbed into common
Caption: knowledge so what happens is that public
Caption: popular culture has distilled it down
Caption: into three generalizations that
Caption: extroverts energetic outgoing and social
Caption: people that introverts shy reserved in
Caption: solitary people and that people only
Caption: exist in one point all the time along
Caption: this continuum now these interpretations
Caption: are useful but also very damaging they
Caption: give us a basic understanding of what
Caption: personality traits are but they ignore
Caption: the properties of the continuum that
Caption: personalities exist along this infinite
Caption: spectrum between the extremes of
Caption: introversion and extraversion and that
Caption: one person while remaining in a general
Caption: area will move around over time by
Caption: misinterpreting the theory people draw
Caption: poor conclusions about how people
Caption: respond to certain situations conditions
Caption: and stimuli up to 40% of the population
Caption: identifies introverts and the list of
Caption: some of the common behavior of
Caption: introverts aren't shown on the board
Caption: because the personality trait continuum
Caption: is a spectrum even extra greats my
Caption: identify was some of these some others
Caption: are as an introvert myself identify with
Caption: almost all of these all of the time
Caption: I want to single this one am particular
Caption: too much stimulation leaves you feeling
Caption: distracted and unfocused and I want to
Caption: read a quote from the article that this
Caption: came from I think it sums up the
Caption: difference between introverts and
Caption: experts and introverts and extroverts
Caption: perfectly unlike extroverts who gain
Caption: energy from social interaction
Caption: introverts expend energy in social
Caption: situations after spending time in a
Caption: large group of people introverts often
Caption: feel the need to recharge by spending a
Caption: period of time alone now I can
Caption: personally vouch for the effects of
Caption: being an introvert working in our open
Caption: plant working environment years of
Caption: working under these conditions affected
Caption: me mentally and physically I was like a
Caption: slow boiling frog I could feel something
Caption: was happening but I didn't know what it
Caption: was and the Simpsons grew a year-by-year
Caption: I could only identify those symptoms so
Caption: I was exhausted almost constantly I was
Caption: stressed and easily irritated beyond my
Caption: breaking point and I couldn't perform my
Caption: work duties to the standard that I knew
Caption: that I was capable of I come to loathe
Caption: going to work every day
Caption: now I practice mindfulness and that does
Caption: help alleviate some of the symptoms but
Caption: the effects are fleeting for the first
Caption: time in my life I ended up needing to
Caption: take medication to manage my anxiety
Caption: levels just because I was going to work
Caption: it made me feel like a failure as a
Caption: human being to see others thriving in
Caption: this environment while I was struggling
Caption: just to survive it's irresponsible for
Caption: employers to not provide adequate
Caption: working conditions for all of their
Caption: employees yeah I met resistance when I
Caption: was proposing changes to the perfect
Caption: open plan model that and the perceived
Caption: benefits that have brought the
Caption: organization I found myself unable to
Caption: convince my employer to change
Caption: environment and I was unable to continue
Caption: working under those conditions so I took
Caption: the difficult decision to leave before
Caption: things really got out of hand it was a
Caption: difficult decision because I was leaving
Caption: behind ten years of great achievements I
Caption: was leaving behind a reputation for
Caption: being able to succeed in the face of
Caption: extreme adversity and I was leaving
Caption: behind more friendship than I've ever
Caption: had and any other time in my life
Caption: so with a decision made I began to find
Caption: in what I wanted for my future employer
Caption: and I focused on what made me happiest
Caption: at work in the past in the workplaces I
Caption: had been happiest in the past for me
Caption: this meant working at a small company
Caption: that was making software for a lot of
Caption: people where I could use all of my
Caption: skills and experience we're colleagues
Caption: openly cared for each other
Caption: and for the customers and where people
Caption: didn't drag each other down for favor or
Caption: reward within the company so fortunately
Caption: I didn't have to wait very long thanks
Caption: for having a great Stack Overflow
Caption: reputation and by registering our sec
Caption: I've applied jobs
Caption: my ideal employer actually found me my
Caption: current job is all the things I wanted
Caption: with the added benefit of being a
Caption: hundred percent remaining I currently
Caption: work from a home in Perth for a company
Caption: called draw board there are Melvin they
Caption: start up there quite mature they're
Caption: already achieving success and we're
Caption: heading to a bright future together
Caption: now lending a remote job is fantastic
Caption: but being effective and successful limit
Caption: is not guaranteed
Caption: after hearing stories from conferences
Caption: like this and from friends I had a good
Caption: idea of some of their challenges I was
Caption: going to face going into it now I'm a
Caption: proactive preparer so I came up with a
Caption: simple action plan I was gonna make my
Caption: environment work for me I was gonna make
Caption: my tools work for me and I was gonna
Caption: establish a strong digital presence so I
Caption: overcome the lack of a physical one so
Caption: after a year I draw blood so far I'm
Caption: happy to say that this approach is
Caption: working great
Caption: I either transition into remote working
Caption: and I succeed at exceeding the
Caption: expectations of my colleagues every day
Caption: my personal oh my my personal happiness
Caption: levels are back to obscenely high levels
Caption: thankfully so here's how I executed on
Caption: this buying as a remote worker you have
Caption: total control over your workspace so put
Caption: in the effort to make sure it works for
Caption: you constantly evaluate what works and
Caption: what doesn't work
Caption: for me this means having a large desk
Caption: with everything I need within my arm's
Caption: reach
Caption: having a nice comfortable office chair
Caption: to sit on having lots of natural light
Caption: that's amazing and having a lot of open
Caption: space don't lock yourself in an office
Caption: why my studies awful eyes open flannel
Caption: and room and I had all that space to
Caption: myself I feel like I can breathe in that
Caption: space
Caption: I'm also lucky enough to have a house
Caption: with open brick and that has really good
Caption: sound dampening qualities modern houses
Caption: are all these flat walls and glass if
Caption: you've got that sort of situation put up
Caption: egg cartons or some sort of sound
Caption: dampening material having no echo is
Caption: really important when you're working in
Caption: that space all the time maintaining a
Caption: presence isn't easy when you're never
Caption: physically at the office so take the
Caption: time to understand your collaboration
Caption: tools that your company uses and
Caption: understand what the benefits are from
Caption: the tools and how to get the best album
Caption: at your all board we use Clubhouse for
Caption: work planning tracking and showing work
Caption: progress we slack for text based chat we
Caption: use zoom and Microsoft teams for video
Caption: based chat and we use confluence for
Caption: documentation for simple dashboard and
Caption: for bringing all the information
Caption: together in one place now I've taken
Caption: time to ensure that I can effortlessly
Caption: get the best out of those tools and I
Caption: use them every day to make sure that
Caption: people can see the progress I'm making
Caption: and what I'm working on make sure you
Caption: acquire the right technology maximize
Caption: the effectiveness of every digital
Caption: activity that you do of course you'll
Caption: need an adequate stable internet
Caption: connection I live in an area where we
Caption: have NBN and it's very stable in my area
Caption: thank God it's only a fifty plan I get
Caption: 47 down and 17 up and it's more than
Caption: enough for what I do for doing your work
Caption: does you need a great quality computer
Caption: that's not gonna choke on the load you
Caption: need as many screens as you feel
Caption: comfortable with and you need a good
Caption: quality keyboard because you're gonna be
Caption: using it every day if you like me and
Caption: you have a portable computer buy this
Caption: one make sure you get a doc so it's
Caption: really good to plug all these
Caption: peripherals into one doc and they have
Caption: one plug that you can just plug it take
Caption: it out and take your computer away so I
Caption: have a surface pro five as a developer I
Caption: do like it has enough grunt to do all my
Caption: development tasks or my video editing
Caption: stuff it's more than enough
Caption: our processor I have a gaming keyboard
Caption: with backlights and that is really good
Caption: yeah a backlit keyboard and I have two
Caption: large 2k monitors plus my surface rate
Caption: and there's more than enough water need
Caption: for collaborating for collaborating and
Caption: video and audio chat you need a high
Caption: definition camera you need a good
Caption: quality directional microphone and you
Caption: need nice cancelling headphones so get
Caption: an HD camera because it's very hard to
Caption: have a conversation when the other
Caption: person is blurry HD actually has the
Caption: opposite effect it makes it feel like
Caption: you're there have a good quality
Caption: directional microphone
Caption: don't rely on internal microphones I
Caption: also suck get a good quality external
Caption: one they're not that expensive and noise
Caption: cancelling headphones are really good
Caption: for eliminating noise but also they
Caption: eliminate feedback so when somebody's
Caption: talking to you through your speakers it
Caption: doesn't go back through the microphone
Caption: and I don't get an echo it's short
Caption: circuits that it's a really positive
Caption: experience for everybody work hard and
Caption: work smart so my favorite productivity
Caption: practice is this use virtual desktops to
Caption: eliminate all of your digital
Caption: distraction so I have three virtual
Caption: desktops I have a work one I have a
Caption: collaboration and communication one and
Caption: have a personal one because I use my
Caption: work computer for personal and working
Caption: so all your email and slack and
Caption: messaging and all those thoughts of
Caption: things on your collaboration desktop and
Caption: they can go nuts in the background while
Caption: you're over here and you work desktop
Caption: not seeing any of it it allows you to do
Caption: your deep work and then when you're
Caption: ready you can just switch over very
Caption: easily and do your collaboration tasks
Caption: so you control their flow of information
Caption: and of course when you're finished we
Caption: can go over and your personal best spot
Caption: and do be involved in as many slack
Caption: conversations as you need but also as
Caption: many as you can stand so it maximizes
Caption: your chance to be visible to everybody
Caption: in the company up Degas your slack say
Caption: is daily at least do it as much as you
Caption: can so it's really important people
Caption: understand how you're feeling because
Caption: they can spot trends that you might even
Caption: not notice because it's new that's how
Caption: him so it gives them the chance to give
Caption: you reassurance and support it's very
Caption: important that you give them the chance
Caption: to do that shared out when people are
Caption: doing great things to help you share
Caption: that when you were doing great things to
Caption: help other people and share that when
Caption: things are going well I'm not going
Caption: right so it's really important it does
Caption: this helps establish really healthy
Caption: communication in culture in your ongoing
Caption: in your company record and post videos
Caption: of the stuff that you're doing because
Caption: nothing showcases your work like video
Caption: does and it's actually really easy to do
Caption: when you're communicating by text show
Caption: you fun site and show your personality
Caption: use your emojis use your memes using
Caption: animated gifs use YouTube video all this
Caption: stuff is really effective and more
Caption: effective than words at times to express
Caption: how you're feeling and it shows them
Caption: your personalities like thing is all of
Caption: yourself to your communication but be
Caption: respectful don't hold your feelings big
Caption: but being respectable respectful of
Caption: other people rest away from the screen
Caption: as much as you can
Caption: one of the things I miss I when I was
Caption: working in an open homework environment
Caption: is a space where I could just go away
Caption: and chill out for five minutes in quiet
Caption: now that I work from home I can do that
Caption: whenever I like and I use it all the
Caption: time the best place to chill out is
Caption: lying on your bed just take five minutes
Caption: out and then you can go back to working
Caption: and you'll smash it for the rest of the
Caption: day it's really important to have that
Caption: sort of option make sure you only work
Caption: during work hours don't be tempted to
Caption: just do that thing on your phone don't
Caption: be tempted to go and do that thing on
Caption: the computer just that one little thing
Caption: no stick to your start and end up and
Caption: take your lunch break if that's what
Caption: your company does it's very important
Caption: document what you're doing as you go you
Caption: create knowledge bombs that when
Caption: somebody comes to you in a couple weeks
Caption: and go hey didn't you do that thing you
Caption: can say yeah just go and read this
Caption: article and then you can get back on
Caption: with doing your work so it keeps you
Caption: distraction free but it also lets the
Caption: company it covers the company for the
Caption: bus factor if you get hit by a bus all
Caption: your stuff is there
Caption: there's no perception problems when you
Caption: work remotely so there's two wanna talk
Caption: about when you have an allocated desk at
Caption: work if you're not sitting at your desk
Caption: people actually wonder where you are and
Caption: why aren't you working that doesn't
Caption: happen you're working from home because
Caption: obviously you don't have a desk why not
Caption: having that association to a desk
Caption: they think that you're working all the
Caption: time and of course you are because
Caption: you're you're saying what you're doing
Caption: and you're showing them what you're
Caption: doing all the time that's really good
Caption: and healthy did not have the perception
Caption: going on that the opposite is also true
Caption: have you ever been in an open plan
Caption: working right sitting at a desk and you
Caption: just deep in thought and you're one your
Caption: worrying about like if someone's looking
Caption: at me now they might think I'm not
Caption: working when we learn and it distracts
Caption: you from what you're doing that doesn't
Caption: happen when you're a motor working you
Caption: don't have that fear anymore it's very
Caption: liberating so I'm really grateful I'm
Caption: grateful to myself for recognizing how
Caption: much pain and sorrow I was in and for
Caption: having the courage to do something about
Caption: it I'm grateful to my current employer
Caption: for finding me for being open to remote
Caption: working because they're not a remote
Caption: working shop if you're given me the
Caption: opportunity to be the most effective
Caption: employee that I can be so I now have
Caption: control over the areas of my working
Caption: life that caused me so much pain in the
Caption: past and are free to work without
Caption: distraction and just simply enjoy
Caption: getting things done I've really
Caption: discovered joy and happiness in my work
Caption: and I've regained balance and peace in
Caption: my life I hope you've learned something
Caption: from this talk that you can apply in
Caption: your own life and I hope you enjoy the
Caption: rest of your confidence
Caption: [Applause]